welcome back this is the hot breath
podcast the show where you learn comedy
from the pros
I'm your host comedian Joel Byers and
this is our series comedians on skype
talking comedy this is the show where
you get to ask your favorite comedians
your favorite comedy questions so if you
want to get involved in these in the
future
you've got to join our Facebook group
it's gonna be linked in the show notes
in the description of this YouTube video
for you to join us connect with comics
from around the world including comics
at the caliber of today's guest who is
needs no introduction one of my favorite
comedians an absolute legend in this
game please bring a round of applause
for the one and only
Jimmy Schubert hot brethren and sistren
no you go get your coffee if you need I
know at your age I figured you had gone
down for a nap for a second yeah I
figured we could have the coffee and
chat see how things are going where
where you look where you living right
now I'm in Atlanta how was it down there
with the cove with 19 you guys are open
it back up that's what it sounds like
yeah Maya my wife and I have been
staying quarantined we haven't really
been going anywhere but apparently we're
opening up tattoo parlors and I guess
salons and all that but I haven't really
I've been trying to stay busy instead of
worried I don't really stay to woke at
this current time because it seems like
a lot of negativity yeah you know first
off I think it's tape politicized the
virus they asked us to stay at home and
we did that and we flatten the curve and
and now I think it's time to go back I
think New York and all along the
associate Carter they're with it where
the where the Amtrak train runs which is
how that disease kind of spread and hit
those you know Boston Philly New York
and Washington DC I think as you went
further west the numbers dissipated
there
think they thought it was going to be
nearly as bad as it was and once you got
west of you know out west people just
are on top of each other
the weather was nicer out here it was a
lot warmer so I don't think we saw the
numbers I mean I think we have 2,500
cases in all California I mean it was it
was yeah I mean it was so the numbers
are I mean and and and these people want
us to stay home for another three months
I think it's ridiculous I think people
are just gonna go you know what after
you I'm going back to work you know I
don't want and I don't want my friends
businesses to fail and I don't want like
your place like the Magic Castle or the
or the Comedy Store or The Improv I
don't want any of these places that
wonder so I think I'm hoping that we get
back sooner rather than later you guys
are at least open yeah and it's but I
still have you know I mean I had
probably three months of work three
months of shows just evaporate into thin
air it's like what about you yeah
everybody everybody did I mean you know
everybody did unfortunately that's the
way that's the way it goes and and you
know I got a couple shows coming up you
know on June 18th to 21st I'm gonna be
in Phoenix at the house of comedy but
that's a room that seats 250 and it only
settled 75 tickets a show and then you
have Rochester New York which is June
4th 5th and 6th I'm gonna be out there
I'm gonna be doing a one stage two in a
parking lot show like the cars are just
gonna come in Park the park right across
the street for a club they build a big
stage which they moved outside and I'll
be doing comedy like that I mean
obviously and I hate the word new normal
I thought could think it's ridiculous I
think they've successfully accomplished
our goals which is they want to make
everybody afraid of each other they
don't want people like associating they
want us talk and they've successfully
accomplished their goal which was to
scare the [ __ ] out of everybody because
of that it's easier to control you know
I think I don't think you're gonna get
this virus I don't think you're gonna
see the W curve which everybody keeps
talking about I just don't think the
numbers are there when according to
Johns Hopkins University
America was more prepared for this virus
we handle it our numbers are much lower
it's it's like you know it's like a 96
percent survival rate I mean a lot of
people that died in pre-existing
conditions they probably were going to
die anyway of some [ __ ] so I mean I'm
not and I'm not being callous here but I
mean I'm because I know a lot of people
lost people they care about a lot of
people did die but Jesus I mean it's
time for us to get back to work I think
we'll see you know I mean at least we
know what we hydroxyl or Kron as this
from Ivan and Xing treatments work you
know I only laugh because like oh we're
all doctors now like we we can hear the
fancy words well I mean everybody wants
to educate themselves yeah you know it's
funny I was supposed to go to I went to
India with Russell Peters in October and
on that trip we were supposed to go to
Nigeria and Kuwait but we never went to
Nigeria but in order to go to Nigeria
the doctor had to prescribe me she gave
me three shots one was a pneumonia shot
something else and then I had to get
hydrochloric all which is the malaria
medication she gave me as this or my
thing which is a z-pack and of course I
have zinc because I take my vitamins but
I actually have it sitting in my cabin
hmm my grad school Dakotas I survived it
so paid the average bro I was gonna say
you could sell it as merch yeah go ahead
you can sell it it hurts at your shows
so people watching go ahead and comment
with your questions thank you for tuning
in here I'm gonna ask Jimmy a few more
questions and then we're gonna get to
yours here yeah oh yeah well you know
you want to educate yourself and you're
right like because
you slipped around since the 1950s it's
$6 a pill mmm-hmm so they won't take it
said a van a thousand yeah but luckily
like we're talking out a lot of shows
getting canceled but now a lot of
comedians are trying to figure out other
ways to find that income when there
isn't that stage and luckily you have a
special and now an album out that yeah
hopefully I mean it's seemingly you know
I just independently release my own
special and it seems to be doing well
based on people just searching seeking
out content house how have you seen the
numbers affected by the quarantine I
mean my album went to number one you
know my specials been out for a year and
we've been said at least you know
steadily selling you know but I mean
because my album wanted number one I
noticed that people are rebuy or buying
and my special so numbers ago when
numbers are good yeah yeah and you went
when I said what have we talked about
this interesting because you
self-produced and self-released it which
is something we talked about mark
Normand on here who no one would pick up
his special so he just do it on youtube
and it seems a lot of people are doing
that but then someone like you Doug
Stanhope went the Vimeo route as well
I'm selling it through my website so I'm
hoping maybe that's the next wave of
specials to where we're not just like oh
my throwing it out yeah well Vimeo Ralph
let me tell you why yes it's a 90/10
split nice if you put it on iTunes
itunes takes 30 percent right off the
top you know I heard a lot of you know
well if you're a minority we would have
bought your special I said well I'm not
about already and that's a really
horrible thing to say to me because you
know I go well you know did you watch
the special they said yeah we watched a
couple minutes but so I said and you
know I ran into this time and time again
and also like comedy dynamics I mean
here's why you know that I asked they
said we'd love your special we wanted I
said what's the offer and they said well
if you pay the three
thousand dollars errors and omissions
insurance is called E&O insurance
because the case somebody Sue's you for
something you say you're covered they
said they wanted me to pay the three
thousand dollars errors and omissions
insurance and then they said they would
throw it on the roku channel and take
50% that was their crop and i said wow
you guys are uh-oh you guys are really
you would do that for me what you know
but these people are they're useless and
they know that you listen in this day
and age with social media and all these
opportunities to you know release and
promote your specials you don't need any
of these people and you own it see you
won't it to see that's the other thing
if i had sold it to any of these
companies it would have ripped the audio
off they would have released the audio
and stole my and stole my ability to
promote myself on my schedule and the
way i wanted to do and so i'm just you
know you know number one was insulting
they try to squeeze me for 3,000 i know
they have the errors and omissions
insurance already because they have a
they have a company that produces comedy
hours so in order for them to be in that
business they would have to have the
insurance they would so we're trying to
squeeze me for 3 grand
so they insulted my intelligence number
one and then number two why would i give
you 50% I mean you know I spent you know
I spent a lot of my own money producing
this why would I give it to you why
would I give you 50% what are you
bringing to the table I mean my record
distributor stand up records they have a
roku channel you can watch their on
their roku channel why would i give it
and you know i don't need you don't need
these people you know anymore and that's
what I'm that's why that's why you see
mark mark Normand is a great comic and
he released his and Sam Morril out of
New York to the same thing and a lot of
these people are doing it and it's as
empowering you know the performers you
know how does that feel though like a
comedian who's been in the game over 30
years like you and done so much I how's
it feel to still be trying to get
squeezed out of like a little
three grand at this point in your career
well that's just the way it's just the
way it is how the business is no I mean
you know people you know if you watched
that movie ray you know about Ray
Charles I mean Ray Charles owned all his
originals he owned all the originals you
should own your stuff you know it's
funny because I talked to my record
distributor dance whistle and stand up
record so it was my partner in producing
this album and the special he said Jimmy
you'd be surprised at how many people
jump at that deal all day long you know
and look I know every morning radio show
in the country I've worked with them for
years these guys are friends of mine
some of these guys they help me promote
it other than those call yet we'll have
you on wob wobba so I can I have access
to that Network
I have access to social media I have
access to you know like you know you
know as long as you're doing your social
media and promote it on podcast like
this you don't need any of these people
and so you know on Vimeo the deal is
it's a 90/10 split so I get to keep 90%
of the money and they take ten and
there's also a rent option on my special
and there's a buy option to rent out 399
you could rent my hour special for four
hours which is less than a cup of coffee
you can own it and it will live on your
Vimeo account for $9.99 which is less
than ten bucks and the out was right
there as well I mean they're pretty good
price points and this this economy so
you know and the album - Mike this is my
favorite album is my best album I've
ever put out zero hounds it's the
funniest album and yeah because I'm
still excited about making people laugh
I love what it is they do so and I just
I just listen to it on the way home
today to get back for this because I did
go visit family in Tennessee and had to
get back so we could do this because I
was so excited about this and getting to
listen to it what I what I learned from
listening to this and I had seen you
live once you had this and this was the
first time I was aware of you but I'd
never seen you perform live and I was
working the Atlanta punchline
I may be Chris red was the headliner
that we can I don't remember but I
member we were in the green room and you
came in and you you were super nice and
you you like asked you almost like asked
for it like if it was okay if you did a
guest spot as if you were like a note
like you were very just like humble I
think he went under your time and like
that was a that was a moment my career
where I was like if someone at his level
is still treating comedy with that
respect we're not coming in with any
assumptions you're not blowing the light
like a pretty I'm pretty sure you went
under time actually like that really
resonated and affected me well you know
you always were always respect I mean I
you know it's obviously I was doing a
guest set on another guy's show I just I
wanted there were you know I would
that's just a respect thing because if
someone came onto my show I want them to
handle it the same way go under the time
don't push the light you know I think
that's just you know I was a it's a
respect thing that because I respected
the headliner yeah as well you know I'm
not I'm not gonna make any assumptions
even though you know it's just it's like
if someone came to me and asked me like
that I would absolutely do a guest set
but you know that's the same way with
you know sell merch you know that
someone's 81 if I sell if you asked me
and you you know and you have you know
and that I have no problem with it
you know it's just if you if you make
assumptions and and think you know like
I mean it's just that's just it's just a
respect thing you know I mean so yeah
whatnot go ahead no please keep going
that thought no I just said it's just
just the way I was raised you know it's
I started the Comedy Store in Los
Angeles so you know I mean everybody was
a big name out there you know Pryor
Carlin so you always there's always a
respect factor you know yeah I mean you
got to well there's so many things
there's so many things you got to do but
the the first one we can touch on is
like you got to work the door and watch
people like Carlin and Robin Williams
and you got to see Jim Carrey before he
was Jim Carrey and Roseanne before she
was Roseanne and maybe making it over
there at one point but that's all you
know that's all under the rug right now
and we're talking about comedy and
got to become best friends with Mitzi
better well it was a better time to do
comedy it was a better time as far as
political correctness mm-hmm you know
there wasn't this whole cancel culture
and the thing I love about this
quarantine you know with these [ __ ]
douche bags this canceled culture
movement like the universe just wouldn't
cancel culture hold my [ __ ] beer and
they canceled everything and how the
[ __ ] do you like how you'd like not
being able to make a living how do you
like not being able to go anywhere how
do you [ __ ] like it you know it's no
fun is it so I think when we come out of
this quarantine I think people may be a
little more and maybe they won't be
because they're [ __ ] douchebags and
that's just the [ __ ] whiteness but um
but I think people be a little bit like
you know it has this thing has a way of
putting things in perspective I think
hard reset button for Humanity period
you know what did you what did you learn
because you were around the comedy store
like us us comedians coming up now like
this is like the folklore of comedy you
know what I mean like the comedy store
house and people like the razor blades
in the comedy store greenroom from like
the partying it's like we hear these as
folklore but you lived it yeah well you
know I survived it you know me and Marin
me mark me mark we're like doormen
together
mm-hmm and we lived in Christ Hill
together which was the house it's every
bit as notorious I mean I'm outlining a
book that I will absolutely tell these
stories in a book but yeah it was
legendary it was crazy it was a
completely different time in the history
of what it was it was the you know was a
it was a way that was like a wave
everybody was just popping off for sitio
was there and and dice and Sam and
pop-pop these guys were the bloke
blowing up I mean you know Garry
Shandling was coming in Louie Anderson
was there I mean guys like Harry basil
and they were just like there was us
like a who's who I mean you could I mean
it really was like my college as far as
I'm concerned but you know
and I party about as much as I did to
college when I was at the Comedy Store
but I'll never forget it it was a great
era and I learned so much by watching
some of the best comedians in the
country you know Paul Mooney and and you
know just it was just it was just a
cavalcade of what you know you got to
watch Pryor come in and build an hour
and watch to watch his process you know
Rob Williams would come in and it was
just like I just uh it was just like a
[ __ ] circus man it was it was fun to
be a part of and some of my best friends
I made there and I'm still friends with
the day you know I mean so yeah I don't
regret it at all but I definitely think
it's worthy of a book for sure oh my
yeah and in researching you there yeah
you you've divulged some of the stories
but I I can oh I can't wait to hear even
more in the book like what are some of
the things you learned from from like
the comedy side getting to be around the
pretty much like the 1% in comedy but
then also getting to observe and watch
like what are what are some things that
you learned because you're 18 years old
getting around all of this yeah well I
was you know you know always worked to
the top of your intelligence was one of
the things I mean you know there's
there's a there's different kinds of
lasts you know like you often talk about
[ __ ] corn in your [ __ ] and and you
know and everybody can make that funny
of course but those aren't the kind of
laughs you want you want you want you
want to you want better laughs than that
and you only acquire that by you know
and it took me a long time to get good
at it believe me it took me like nine
years to get to a point where I thought
it was funny enough to like headline
rooms you know I always I didn't find my
voice until after you know I left Los
Angeles after Kinison died and I just
wanted to start over so I went to
Florida and kind of started working as a
house emcee and I was doing comedy six
nights a week but I had all this I had
this foundation of knowledge about what
to do and what not to do and so it
really it helped me find my voice
I didn't find my voice tell us about
nine or ten years and it was only by
doing it every single night of the week
six nights a week with 45 minutes a
night on stage that's what I really kind
of found my found my voice and and and
just and you know that it's and because
I have a passion for this I love to do
it it's just gotten better over time you
know I love there's nothing I love more
than creating a nice piece of comedy
that makes people laugh like I still
that still turns me on still why I do it
whereas before I used to party a little
bit and now the party is what you get to
create put on stage you know yeah and
you really are a craftsman in one of my
favorite lines from your your new album
zero tolerance which is available
believe it's I mean I got it on iTunes
but I think it's available platforms
yeah you know you've got it you've got
to check this out because this is a
comedian 30 years in at the top of the
game and like what I what I love when
you talk about you like crafting a joke
what two things I noticed from listening
to you that I'd like to maybe
individually get into but one is like
your Annunciation on stage you are very
particular and you're making sure people
understand what you are saying and also
your word choice you know it seems like
you have a very clever and specific way
like a line that stuck out was you
talking about the self-checkout and I'll
just ladle the hot liquid into my hand
and I'll lick it off my blistered like
you seem you could have just said yeah
I'll just pour it into in my hand and
then I'll just drink it out but you're
like ladle the hot liquid blistered
hands like you seem to be very specific
in the wording well because you're
payton pictures with words you're paying
pictures with words you creating this
visual image in people's heads and
especially on an album that really
creates a visual image in people's minds
and and you know gods in the details I
think the more specific you can get the
funnier it's gonna be you know Carlin is
obviously George Carlin's one of my
heroes I love George Carlin I
I love the way you play with language I
love the way pulled it apart put it back
together again you know and that's
really like the kind of things you got
your toolbox you know you got
phraseology you got you got you got
wording how can I put a whole paragraph
in one sentence mm you know how can I
you know it's word efficiency as well
and you know I really I like having my
own vernacular there's a lot of words on
there that you know you kind of make up
words because you find laughter in
places where there wouldn't be laughs
normally you know what I mean
I mean you you you know there's funny
things you're saying the setups you know
I got you know it's a I just liked it I
like peppering and layering a bit I mean
I like it to be layered cuz the jokes
are having a couple different levels you
know there's you know what you're trying
to say overall with a piece like this
and then you know I like to theme my
hour I like I like a theme to run
through the album you know that's just
you know like almost like a one-man show
which I want to you know so it takes me
you know takes about two years to get my
the to where you have a solid [ __ ]
hour that works like that and then you
know the the album is different from the
special so there's a couple different
things that are on the CD that are not
in the special and vice versa because I
want to do it like that I want there
always be a little something extra you
know and how let's let's go back to you
saying how can I put a whole paragraph
into one sentence like can you break
that down for us are you going pen to
paper writing out the entire paragraph
and then going back and editing out
unnecessary words how do you condense
that well you know everything starts out
as a first off I find something that
irritates the [ __ ] out of me okay okay I
find something that I really am
genuinely frustrated about whether it's
dealing with the TSA or dealing with the
certain things in life that you do that
just seem ridiculous now I'm gonna have
a field day with this whole lockdown
Cove of 19 when we come out I got about
30 new minutes I can't wait to get on
stage to try but it starts with a
genuine what
the frustration is real so don't so when
I speak about something there's an
authenticity to it that you get that's
not faked so when I'm generally [ __ ]
angry about something I'm generally
about and I'm a ranter you have to
balance a rant with just the right
amount of rage but also it has to be
identical and accessible to people in
the audience to go yeah like you can't
begin you can just and then at the end
you're gonna pull back and laugh at
yourself letting people know a joke that
you know that you're not really that
[ __ ] angry about it is this little
it's a little dynamic with it and then
also it's like you know I like I just I
over right I'm over right and then I
scale back and then I always go you
don't give me 20 facts I'll give you 20
jokes give me 20 facts I'll give you 20
jokes so let's say you're talking about
something and then I go down a rabbit
hole on internet search as I try to find
all the information about what I'm
talking about so I discuss something I
want to know where I can go with it so
where I can go so I can go so you know
and I need that because in the middle of
if someone says something I can also
come off with a fact that'll blow them
away like right now on eBay there are
24,000 listings for therapy animal
certifications vests leases badges so
most of these animals are not therapy
animals essentially what the airline's
did is it would charge of people seventy
five dollars for them to bring their
animals on the airplane or fly in the
airplane and and so they wouldn't charge
you if it was a therapy [ __ ] animal
but I gotta be honest with you it's
[ __ ] ridiculous I fly all the time
it's bad enough I got to go to [ __ ]
Cleveland I'm not bringing the [ __ ]
tiny Pony with me because that's just
[ __ ] obnoxious but so I just like the
research and have cuz but by going and
doing the research of printing up some
stuff
then you highlight some of this points
thing and then you just start to gather
it and then once you've got because it
really almost starts out as a lecture
mm-hmm and then and then I just kind of
go and well that's what this could be
funnier here and this could be funnier
here and this could be and then I try to
insert
and find these places where I can search
these jokes so you know it's really just
kind of a like a one-way conversation
you're having with the audience but I
wanted to but I want to know what I'm
talking about I don't want to just go up
there making [ __ ] up I I think you know
cuz people always go that's [ __ ]
hilarious and it's true and it's true I
want I wanted to be that that that kind
of foundation and then of course one of
the one of the comedy formulas that I
use quite successfully is the over
exaggeration mm-hmm that's how many the
thing you know you know Brian Regan does
that in a way as well I mean if you know
what your comedy formulas are that's one
that the over exaggeration of it it's
become ridiculous it'd be funny but yeah
yeah you know it's so and I like great
references I like you know like you said
I like painting pictures with words I
like I like you know and find find out
stuff but obviously I think most the
most of the work I do is offstage in the
writing mm-hmm you know and because you
know if you're doing this for 30 years I
know who I am I know how to make
something funny I know how to make
another one I'm gonna make it funny but
not to make it funny to fit me you know
yeah and that here's a great yeah please
go ahead please please now go ahead you
go first
good yeah I was just thinking about the
yeah your specific writing and that
you're still mindful of how valuable
that is because a lot of comics think
they can get away with just having
attitude up there but there's gotta be
there's got to be that structure behind
it and I'm great I'm glad you're showing
us that well you know the funny thing is
you know anybody it's just [ __ ] lazy
yeah sorry it's [ __ ] lazy yeah and
you know if you're doing look I know
some guys do crowd work great some guys
are really great at it you know if I
want but I also think that that's not
the audience's job the audience job is
to sit back and laugh and and you want
them to know they're in the hands of a
capable professional you know I mean
it's also what you're talking about
there's so many [ __ ] things in the
world to talk about and you want to go
talk about a [ __ ] tinder date I said
nobody gives a [ __ ]
nobody gives a [ __ ] people just don't
care they want to laugh and they wanted
to be accessible to them stand-up comedy
is really like in every man's art form
you know what I mean they have to feel
like you're one of them you know and and
so you have to be accessible
I almost arrive at the punchline and
just a few seconds before the audience
does it yeah
I was thinking that too I just said that
the other day you know I mean like that
kind of thing
look there's so many levels of if you're
talking about this like like there's so
much nonverbal communication it goes on
like you know what you wear says so much
about you before you even [ __ ] open
your mouth
so what you wear on stage should be
should say what you're trying to say
before you [ __ ] say it
if you'll notice Doug Stanhope wears the
same thing Andrew Dice Clay wears the
same thing Sam Kinison also like a human
[ __ ] cartoon you know I mean some
guys it's almost like a you know it's
just kind of he wanted to say what you
want to say before you before you open
your mouth you know boom yeah did you do
those that you would learn after you've
been doing it [ __ ] 30 years you know
I want to yeah it's it's listen I love I
love I love doing it still you know I've
had a amazing life and and I'm not
bitter and I'm not jaded and I don't
think the [ __ ] world owes me anything
and if I'm able to make a living doing
something I love to do then I'm [ __ ]
way ahead in the [ __ ] curve anyway
yeah I had a blast
I've been all over the world I've been
to China Singapore Macau I've been the
you know Ireland and Israel and Dubai
and just doing shows for expat
communities or also do shows for the
military Armed Forces entertainment
Department of Defense I mean I went to
Afghanistan remember just popped up with
my Facebook feed with with Drew Carey
and Steve Byrne and in pedro diniz the
day before daya we went over there did a
bunch of shows a really aggressive kind
of 11 day tour of Afghanistan where we
did all these forward-operating bases
you know I've also been to Armed Forces
entertainment where with the cubicle wa
tottemo Bayon Andros Island and
El Salvador and Honduras and you get to
and the great thing is I get the travel
experience which i think is amazing I
wanna my passport stamp looks like I'm
an international spy
you know so does that have yeah
wait you performed at Guantanamo Bay
yeah what was that like and I'm gonna go
get a hat as well I want to match you
please let them know what it was about
I'll be right back
well what animal bait was pretty awesome
but you know you have to do this kind of
they have to do come flying into a
really small airplane and you guys do
this like pin wheel turn and and by
doing this pin wheel turn it's it's it's
only one tottemo air base that has that
because it's a it's a narrow runway so
you're really going to do this hairpin
turn and then come down at this runway a
90-degree angle which gets a little uh
which gets a little ridiculous but yeah
it was cool helmet that looks great
thanks I thought you would appreciate it
yeah there we go
so yeah you know we're adding we're
adding comedy into this as well that's
awesome so I've never done this in an
interview but I thought I could match
the guests as we're getting into the
comedy nerdom is this offending you
Jimmy
no okay I think it looks great
thank you it's a good choice good choice
thank you very much buddy
so let's uh let's get into the the
viewer questions um gosh I love getting
to do this getting to ask commune's like
you these girl I could like I could talk
about this all day but I want to make
sure we get into these questions as well
and just in researching you comics dive
into Jimmy's like life if you were like
a not aware of his backstory but I mean
this guy he was on the road with Sam
Kinison for five years he I mean he's a
this is this is a comedy
asset that you need to be studying and
you need to be learning from as much as
possible so thank you again for taking
time to do this Jimmy well you know
because a lot of you know a lot of
people helped me over the years you know
work in the Comedy Store I think that's
the way the art form survives is if you
share your knowledge with people that
are trying to come up and and and and
help them out a little bit because it
really is a ridiculously an incredible
incredibly tough business you know and
you know I so you need all your
resources it's like you know I think
this quarantine or this thing that we're
going through I think a lot of comics
are probably going to get out of the
industry just because they're like fine
I don't want to you know if this is they
may not come back from this that's
number one and number number two is
there may be some people that are that
are not doing in their life what is they
love they may try to get into Congress
so but you know it's long after I'm gone
this is this I love this art form I
think it's amazing and I think it's
really kind of like the First Amendment
right kind of summed up in like this one
occupation is that you get up there you
could say whatever it is that you want
but also you realize it comes to
tremendous responsibility and being able
to present things that like you know you
know you should do it there's a way to
do it you know some people want to be
edgy for [ __ ] edgy sake and talk
about you know cancer and rape and all
that [ __ ] but I got this where I think
it's [ __ ] ridiculous I think what you
should do first is be able to make a
roomful of people laugh because you're a
[ __ ] comedian I think you should be
able to make them [ __ ] laugh and a
lot of stuff I find it to be a lot of it
so can kind of a contrived like a
contrived edginess like they get off on
just being ridiculously fun you know
some people do it they make it look easy
some people are great at it but you know
it's like if you're just starting out
and you want to be one of these guys
like you're gonna it's gonna be a lot
tougher of a road
you know there's a lot of ways to make a
living you make a living in comedy clubs
you make a living doing corporate events
you can make a living playing casinos
only now because there's a lot of
casinos out there you can make your
living doing cruise ships now and if you
think about this like 30 years ago so
we're not any of these avenues to make a
living doing this I mean this is
relatively a new kind of a not like
relatively a new situation I mean you
can make an argument to say it's like
the second oldest profession in the
world you know but you know this is the
way we do comedy in this country it is a
uniquely American art form like jazz
music is uniquely American art form and
they're both kind of similar so I mean
you know I guess to each his own it's
just you know people want to take that
it just depends you got to think about
the big picture you know and you got to
run to hit like a business you got to
run your social media like a business
you got to run your you got to run it
like a [ __ ] business first off you
can have a color scheme your color
scheme should match your website it
should match your Twitter your Facebook
fan page and your Instagram page it
should be uniform across the board
you're building a brand and you know
this is a I'm like I said before man
it's an incredibly difficult profession
so a lot of guys try to put the social
media cart before the horse and if you
know you gotta you know you gotta you
gotta build the act you gotta find out
who you are on stage yeah and I feel
like a lot of the time know that it's
all relevant and that's that's what I
was thinking a lot of comics now more
than ever I feel like try to kind of
microwave the success and focus on the
business before they focus on having
something to sell yeah exactly
you're absolutely you can't like wave
success by the way just so you know
you're gonna fall on your face a bunch
of times and figure out you know you'll
probably do 1,500 things wrong before
you figure out what the right thing is
and that's and that's of every bit of
part of it that's how you become a
[ __ ] amazing [ __ ] headliner oh I
don't like to host
I think hosting is the most important
job on the show I agree I think if
you're a great host then you'll be a
great feature act and if you're a great
feature act then you'll be a great
headline and these are the building
blocks that everybody has to go
you don't just go for freaking you know
I'm gonna go by right the headliner you
can understand look at the show there's
the star of the show you know I mean
people may like this guy or like you
know people like you know you here's a
great example like you're sitting there
after a show and people come up to you
and I loved you drunk about that yeah
and it wasn't your joke it was the
feature I drunk and someone come on I
love that sir no that wasn't my job that
was the MCS joke what it does is it all
runs together they can't differentiate
between the jokes he MC did the joke to
featurette then so I just draw thanks
man I used to make it like pointed out
but doesn't make a difference I just go
thanks I'm glad you enjoyed it
I don't because it's late people don't
look at this the way way stand-up
comedians do so you know I got tired of
arguing with people pointing it out yeah
oh just go thanks a lot man glad you
enjoyed it
all right yeah you know this you know
some guys look at this as a way to run a
bar CH way to run a bar tab and and [ __ ]
waitresses and if that's what you're
doing you should get the [ __ ] out of the
business because it's not going to
sustain you it's not going to sustain
you this is a [ __ ] business I had a
book or tell me this one time he said
doesn't make a difference
life stuff doesn't make a difference not
funny or because it goes because Jimmy
and I'm a Booker I should be saying that
but there's guys that I can book that it
will be funny enough that will do the
job but they also won't trash my hotel
room they won't get drunk and try to
[ __ ] away cuz they won't get drunk to
try to do this and they will you know
trash the hotel room and everybody go
boy that was really you know sometimes
guys just book acts like that because
they know they're dependable but you
know it's you know you're gonna be doing
this a long time look look at those
success like you know it takes guys 20
years 25 years to get successful in this
industry you know I mean look I start
with Marin we were both kids worked in
that success until he got later on in
life you know it's you know now he's a
you know he's at the David Bowie movies
and he was just in the the Joker I mean
you know he's getting exactly he's on
glow you know ladies a restless
glamorous life I mean these guys you
know he's this podcast you
so it took him a long time it takes a
long time you know so you have to
embrace that but you know be thinking
long-term what's your long-term plan
what's your long-term goals you know
what is what is success to you I'm
already successful I've been in movies
I've had my own Comedy Central special
I'm also smart enough to write producing
my own specials and CDs I've produced
every single one of my CDs and you know
I got residual money coming from when
they play me on the radio which you know
is great an ultra strip income I've done
enough acting work that I have a pension
fund and I have insurance for the Screen
Actors Guild
I also also get paychecks like sometimes
I go to my mailbox
they'll be $1,500 in there is this
residual some stuff I've done off right
before this pandemic it I was over in
South Korea for March 2nd to the 9th
working on season 2 of a cross-cultural
kdrama that's usually popular around the
world but here not so much but the
show's called drama world the first
season is actually on Netflix so I'm
over there at worked on for five days
and shot season two which they paid me
enough money that I'm not worried about
the pandemic so I mean I have an acting
career you know I I mean I get to go to
the Magic Castle
I'm a magician remember of the Magic
Castle so I can perform there when I
want to I get to perform at The Comedy
Store that the the
The Improv the Ice House the flappers I
mean you know look this is actually the
career in life I wanted to have then I
get to make my little bit doing stand-up
comedy I love doing close-up magic I
also like acting you know and I get to
produce my own albums and create content
so yeah I mean it's a good life do I
want to be Dane Cook you know not really
and and and not everybody does I mean
some people successful where you make
you know $150,000 a year and you're just
famous enough that you can go out to
restaurants and nobody will [ __ ] come
up to you and yell in your face or or
you know bother you while you're eating
I mean that's the kind of quiet money
like you know a lot of these guys are TV
writers make
make a lot of money and nobody knows who
they are and then go out to eat with
their wives or their kids and nobody
comes up and bothers them that's that it
depends what you want what do you want
there's a lot of ways to go in this
industry you become a voiceover actor
you become a voiceover actor I know guys
do voiceovers put them in a completely
another tax bracket they do voiceovers
for commercials and cartoons big money
also guys who just do commercials
they're just actors in commercials some
guys are extremely successful at that
and that puts you in another category
you know and some guys want to be
writers they want to write sitcoms you
know they don't want to tour on the road
I mean there's a lot of ways to go you
should figure out what it is you want to
[ __ ] do and and then and then find out
guys that you like and respect to do
that and and find out all the
information you can about how their
career happened how they got there and
just lay that template over your life
and figure it out you know boom oh yeah
that's gold figure out what you want
look at who is doing it very well and
find out their template that's great
yeah and apply to your life yeah you
know you know the harder you work the
luckier you get
you know you know some guys like doing
stand-up in LA but during the week they
work on TV shows they write for TV shows
and it's a very lucrative profession
that some guys who just do cruise ships
and make 3 grand 5 grand a week they
don't got to worry about social media
they can want a crew shift and do a week
on a cruise ship they're done you know
what are you gonna do I mean it depends
what you want to do what will make you
happy if you just want to make a living
doing something you want to do which is
making people laugh there are a lot of
ways to go about it you know if you want
to aspire to be something else like a
famous actor and stuff like you know
then take some acting classes that's
what I did I went to a creative a
performing arts high school and I
majored in drama you know I was I was a
professional magician when I was 13 and
14 I mean literally when I think about
this it goes I get crazy because I knew
what I wanted to do when I was like
eight or nine years old and that's
really yoni event
I had as I figured it out early and
everything I'd get up at that point was
leading up to the fact that I would do
stand-up when I was old enough to go to
the comedy clubs and as soon as I was I
did and you know and thank God I did
because you know like you said well you
know you know and and you know look I
got a little lost along the way that
good news is we're uh way ahead of
schedule you know I mean so you know I
mean you know I've been you know I've
done I did like 15 episodes of the King
of Queens I was on I did like four
episodes of Entourage a couple episodes
er two Broke like you've done a lot yeah
a little lost on the way a lot of
listener I mean not everybody can act
you know but that you don't realize you
know like you know I was in a movie go
coyote ugly one-hour photo you were that
creates an alternate stream of income
you could pay for that stuff with you
know for yeah so it's like you know you
you know it's also I have a pension fund
because of all the years I've been
acting I also have you know my health
care because before the Union so I like
having that I can I like having the
Screen Actors Guild because that's how
it looks it's like a union that looks
after you know nice awesome and this
this can tie into actually the first
question as we are in quarantine and
you're talking about people finding
different streams of income and Sasha is
actually asking this is more from the
the skill development side he says I
spend a lot of my time on the writing
aspect of stand-up do you have any
recommendations for what I can do off
stage or at home that can help me
improve in the performer aspect of
comedy yeah well here's well there's a
couple things writing so I would say
this is great exercise someone told me
this one and shake it up every day and
read a newspaper from cover to cover
hmm you read a newspaper from cover to
cover that way you could almost talk
about anything and know what's going on
in the world today
you know which would help your writing
also I find when I'm writing I'm also
reading a lot like Irene I got four
books going just because you know you're
looking for inspiration and stuff like
that and I find what I'm writing a lot I
also find myself reading a lot I don't
know what it is I'm a voracious reader
anyway but like when I'm writing and you
know take a break and I walk I just go
read a couple chapters of this or a
couple chapters here and try to find
inspiration that way I try to look for
ideas that no one's talking about but it
to address his question he was talking
about the performance-wise what can you
do and I think you just have to believe
in yourself I know that's easier said
than done but listen you know you should
learn to channel the nervousness the
nerves you should learn to channel that
because he was the question was what can
I do at home to get better performing
yes yeah so that's so look we all got
nerves I mean I used visual a chinois I
use meditation you know visualize myself
killing on stage I visualized myself
being very comfortable in front of the
audience I visit I you know I mean if
you do the work off stage you see that
if you do the work off stage that should
translate into confidence on stage so if
you're doing the writing you're doing
that the net should look at just people
the worst thing that can happen is
they're not going to [ __ ] laugh big
deal I got news for you that will happen
all throughout your career you will run
across a [ __ ] dumb audience it
doesn't get it and I used to say there
were no no such thing as a bad audience
but there are so but you know it's are
you are you there Herzing your material
does that help with the performance side
well I would say rehearsing memorizing
okay
memorize memorizing like you know I got
a couple things here that I'm working on
you know and I go over it and I try to
memorize it I mean look I know how to
present
obviously when I think you've asked me
six questions we've been doing this for
an hour
I mean I I obviously have a gift of gab
I like to [ __ ] run my cankle but my
rehearsing so I know where I'm going
with it I know where the jokes are I
know where the beets are it's like like
acting like you know you want to
memorize a script and if you know the
script then when you take it on stage
then you can play with it because you
know it so well mmm
but is it I used to watch Robin Williams
and when your rots Robin you know good
man this guy's improvising this whole
act not really after you watch him like
six nights in a row you realize it's the
same man he's just doing it out of order
he's just bouncing off the audience and
letting it take him in the direction it
goes and you could only do that when you
know your act so well you have to know
it so well because then you go onstage
and you could [ __ ] play with it you
know people think you know people watch
a lot of louis c.k and i think oh he's
just talking to one Elaine's I guarantee
he's not talking to lines I guarantee
you he's working those [ __ ] bits
almost every single word of those bits
was with precision why do I say it like
this as opposed to this believe me I
mean you know it's only your [ __ ] Act
you so you put so much thought into it
and the construction of an idea and a
premise and a bit and then you got to go
up on stage and act like it's the first
time you're saying it mm-hmm
that's kind of where the thing is but
yeah I think you just got to know your
material know it front foot sideways
backwards like I can do mine I can do my
act backwards forwards sideways you know
up and down and and when you can do that
then it will give you a freedom on stage
so you could then jump in the oils do
some crowd work bounce back into a bit
go back over here bounce back a little
bit do this bit out of one or let that
bit lead you into this bit and it would
seem like wow this guy's just kind of
seems like he's making this stuff up on
the spot but only because you know
exactly where you go you know yes all
right
great yeah great answer great question
as well Sasha
the next one from Justin Williams he
says hello sir please tell us about
stand-up records and how you got a deal
with them and he follows up with I found
your album on Spotify how do those deals
operate similar to Vimeo uh no when I do
play on Spotify you do get paid again
creating an alternate stream of income
so it's not a lot of money but it's a
deal with the deal with the state of
Records as I've been doing business with
dance whistled stand-up records for 20
years I produced my first album and it
happened by accident I was planning on
it anyway and I worked at this club that
was in Midvale Utah and they had a like
an amazing recording system and the guy
said yeah he goes pay me like you know
and I paid like 75 bucks for him to
record all my shows and give me the dat
tapes and then the next week I went to I
was in Jacksonville Florida and I went
to the phone book and looked up a guy
who could transfer those dat tapes into
cassette tape so I could listen to him
and come up with some editing notes and
that and by the time I get done and
everyday i'ma go over that dudes house
he was a he was a musician and he had a
studio and I think I paid him like 350
bucks to help me cut the album and
that's what I did I cut the album put it
together and then I had a publicist to
new dance little she sent it to him he
said yeah I'd like to I'd like to
produce this and then so and then ever
since then we've just been doing
business together I like games because
there's an independent label because
he's an honest and as fair as they come
not a lot of people know about the
recording it's because you're not you
think oh there's some of my my CD for
like 10 bucks well that's not the way it
works really because what you do is you
wholesale a DVD you wholesale CD and
DVDs so you wholesale to him so maybe
you sell to a company for six bucks and
then you know that there's markup you
know and then you have a middleman and
then negative taste and then when it
gets left right down to it
you you and me me and my partner which
is dance little split what's left over
so but XM serious there's a thing called
sound exchange sound exchange is a
company you should register with if you
intend on doing albums because sound
exchange keeps track of every time you
played on the radio and maybe they may
be playing you on the radio and you're
unaware of and so there's money out
there so you register with
you should then set up an account with
Pandora amp because Pandora amp is for
creators like me it's like you could
leave message hey this is Jimmy Schumer
takes a list of Jimmy Scheuer channel
listen just won't let you guys know I've
been in Lake City on these days and what
happens is Pandora takes that ad and
then the because you mentioned Lake City
they'll play that on all the Pandora's
in Atlantic City to let people know
you're coming
hey thanks to listen my channel thanks
Liz my album hey Jimmy Schubert I got a
new CD a brand new CD and you can leave
these little announcements for your fan
base and you should build your fan chant
Chad Daniels as a guy who's had
tremendous success with Pandora amp you
know you know you work you are a creator
you should be looking at all this stuff
you should be looking at empowering
yourself and but but also you should be
doing the work on your act as well but
you should be investigating all these
things they're all out there they're all
tools that you know we get to use so
gorgeous yeah and we've actually we're
we're working on getting in contact with
Chad to get him on here cuz he's been
highly requested so that's great Pandora
amp that's good I hadn't heard of that
so I'll definitely look into that yeah
definitely looking for amp and they do
and they do online seminars to teach you
how to use it
oh nice yeah perfect yeah it's a Pandora
and playbook and especially for a guy
who doesn't really have a record deal
you can take some of your recordings and
as long as the CPU number and you can
upload them and create content for your
channel and then you can leave messages
for your fan base in between there so
it's really a great tool to have and
it's just you and if you once you set it
up you can both put a link to it on your
social media and on your you know your
put a link to it on your website and
everything else you know awesome great -
ma'am this is woo
this turning is so much more than we
were expecting here so thank you
Jimmy next one yes this guy J Frank he
was saying Jimmy with four exclamation
marks he's very excited and we'll just
do like two more here
Jimmy great album you're a legend this
is J Frank by the way Jimmy great album
you're a legend it was nice meeting you
through Joe and touchy and cannot G
brother does that make the how is
hanging out with uncle lar how crazy is
that brother uncle uncle uncle air sorry
uncle eras there's a UH a Chicago
comedian he's a legend himself a Glary
reap right and so yeah I love Larry's is
a great comedian also a great guy but
yeah you know and again you know you
know uncle lair has this thing is a
great great piece of advice by the way
so I write a joke and you want stage you
do a joke and a joke that's a laugh I'll
do it like all the left is you take one
word out until a joke doesn't get a
laugh and then you put that one word
back in and then you done with the piece
you done with the bit you know when you
write so you know as an example to get
word officially writes a joke it's a
laugh mm-hmm and then he slowly takes
one word out one word out come on we're
up til doesn't you laugh and they put
said we're back in and leaves it though
so he knows it's more efficient but yeah
yeah I yeah that's great yeah yeah great
a great great great story there we got a
good nugget out of that so let's go yeah
let's get into this final one here and
Joon sang nice I just had a light bulb
moment I've become a slave to my
transitions on leading me in a specific
order need to revisit how I've been
writing to be able to bounce more in
different direct
I'm a total rookie well you know what I
do you know because I do 45 minutes to
an hour on stage every night and as a
trick what I do
June is I lay little bread crumbs
because I may mention something about
what I'm getting ready to talk about in
a previous bit or I may mention
something about two bits from there just
to leave me these little bread crumbs so
it goes like some also to remind me that
that bits coming up to remind me that
I'm getting ready to talk about
something it to remind me slightly these
little kind of little bread crumbs in my
act
that I mean because you know 45 minutes
to an hour is a long time and so you
want to have a way to remind yourself of
that and so built in my bits or these
little not remind me that oh yeah that
bits coming up right that bit you know
so let's yeah let's let's end with this
and maybe we can parlay it into like a
question we had here about who is your
favorite performer ever and like what is
your favorite joke ever but then also
what is your favorite comedy advice ever
like what is something that you've
gotten that just really helped you or
just advice that you just never
forgotten that's really become kind of a
pillar all right yes all right my
favorite comedian ever is George Carlin
okay I said that before but Carlin I
mean the guy's got you know 21 albums 14
HBO specials eight books he was a
Content monster I don't think anyone
will ever come close to that I think
he's just aged just I want and back when
Carlin was doing it it was just enough
to be a great community you don't have
to do all this other [ __ ] and also if
you look at some of his best baseball vs
football I mean it's it's just so well
crafted and it's a long bit and I just
I'm just a huge George Carlin fan it
doesn't get any better that favorite
piece of advice I said before always
work to the top of your intelligence
it'll separate you from the crowd I
always get my audience's credit for
being intelligence I was giving my craft
my audience credit for being smart
enough to get to joke you know I mean
and and you know yeah if you work to the
top of your intelligence you
automatically separate yourself from the
from the pack because most people aren't
thinking at that level and numbered and
it's my favorite joke is only because I
want to joke telling contest with this
Joe and I want a Keurig at a golf outing
with Kevin James and Ray Romano they
have this joke telling contest and you
know so guy goes to the doctor he's got
a big gash in his upper thigh and I says
doc I think I'm gonna need some stitches
and doctor says yeah it looks like it
drop your pants and the guy drops your
pants and the doctor goes holy [ __ ] you
have brown balls he goes doc just
stitched me up here and let me you know
get back because I got stitched you up
but I'm telling you you got brown balls
so doctor said she's muppets little
gauze bandage on it and the guy goes
home and starts pitching his wife goes
god damn it honey you keep this place
looking like a pigsty I'd slip pulling
the kids rollerskate I cut my leg on the
edge of the table had to get stitches
and the wife goes listen you son of a
[ __ ] I am the mother of eleven of your
children I'm pregnant with the twelfth I
don't even have time to wipe my ass he
goes and that's another thing I want to
talk so there you go that's my favorite
that's my favorite Street job yeah it's
just the build-up and the pacing it's
yeah it's awesome great way to end here
Jimmy Schubert please let the hot breath
verse nowhere they can check out your
album and your special and just so
booked everything's available and
accessible through Jimmy Schubert calm
and that's sherbert it's Shu ber G it's
spelled like the theatre
not there's no seeing Schubert or you
can go get my zero tolerance album on
iTunes which if you're a young upcoming
comic I think you should get it because
that it's it's almost like a kind of a
writing seminar to you know like this
there's there really is you know you
should get in just just because it gives
you ideas where you can go with pitch
then you're not even thinking about you
know and you can follow me on Twitter
Jimmy sherbert and Instagram it should
be sherbert you follow my Jimmy Schumer
comedian page on Facebook
and if you go to my website it'll take
you all those places but yeah go get my
album it's really it's really it's my
fourth album I'm really proud of it I
think it's at Larry's thing funny it's
57 minutes of non-stop bang bang bang
old-school setups punchlines callbacks
it's just the way it is
I says how we do and yeah so if people
are and anyway thanks for having me on
man
yeah appreciate it yes yeah I hope that
I hope you I hope you guys got something
out of it the people listen I hope you
got a little something out of it and so
everybody stays safe throw into
quarantine and enjoy your life and good
luck with your careers a breath you're
not going to ask me one of the you're
not going to ask me two questions like
James Lipton
on the Actors Studio okay what's your
favourite swearword mr. Shubert
[ __ ] all right things out Jimmy
appreciate it buddy ha prep averse go
support Jimmy Schubert everything will
be linked in the show notes